when it's not part of your culture to
talk about feelings in that way you
don't you don't talk about it with
anybody I didn't I don't really talk
about it with my friends you know I was
I did I did write some sad songs in
college maybe that was a good outlet but
maybe not good enough it was about three
months ago that I went to a doctor to
try and get some help for certain
feelings that I have work that were just
debilitating socially that I've had for
my entire life that I thought you know
what I could just deal with this I've
dealt with it for 32 years
one day you say to yourself I said to
myself enough enough I'm getting help
went to a doctor
she sat me on a couch she asked me a
bunch of questions by the end of it they
had determined that I had symptoms of
major depression
she said hey do you want to try
medication and like some therapy and I
said okay told my fiancee how it went
she was like what and I was like yeah
depression I don't want to call that I'm
not ready to say it's depression one
question that the doctor asks do you
have feelings of worthlessness every day
most people you hear someone say that
you assume they're joking like uh Jared
that's a--that's a funny guy but no I
it's real do I know that it's irrational
yes sometimes the doctor prescribed
lexapro I went to Target and got a
generic version she said they're not a
cure-all and I don't I wasn't looking
for them as a cure August just anything
to like change
my behavior in a way where I could just
move forward instead of just staying in
one spot and not doing anything about it
there were immediate effects when I
started taking the pills and there were
they're pretty physical I felt a little
more aware of my body I can see how that
that awareness of your body can help you
like pull yourself out of your head and
maybe that's one of the desired effects
of the medication I thought that my
breathing problems were because I wasn't
healthy and maybe I am a little bit I
should probably work out more but I I
felt less anxiety and that cost me to
breathe better at night I had bloating
that I wasn't really aware of I thought
I was just like a little fatter just
from being older at the same time it
made it a little harder to get out of
bed but I've got things to do and I make
myself get out of bed because I have
people that count on me like loved ones
so I can imagine for someone who doesn't
have that support system and that
routine it could be more debilitating I
hadn't like sought help in the past
because I didn't feel like I needed it I
didn't I didn't feel like I deserved to
feel bad about anything like I likes
pretty good like hike I'm not hungry I
got most of my teeth yeah it's just like
this weird cycle of like you feel shitty
but you don't deserve to and you just it
doesn't stop and I do think the pills
the medication has helped me like
alright stop doing that not rational
thinking let's just take a step back
let's get outside of your head and let's
just do the things that you got to do
I'm not completely worthless
so there's that you know mental health
you're not completely worthless